>>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS IN
A LEGAL BATTLE ARGUING THAT
DONALD TRUMP'S LAWYERS SHOULD
NOT GET TO SEE THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS SEIZE AT MAR-A-LAGO
DURING THE UPCOMING SPECIAL
MASTER REVIEW.
AS THAT APPEAL PLAYS OUT, KRB
CNN HAS LEARNED TRUMP'S TEAM
TOLD THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES THAT
THE MISSING WHITE HOUSE
DOCUMENTS WERE JUST 12 BOXES OF
NEWSPAPER CLIPPINGS.
BUT THEN THEY HANDED OVER 15
BOXES.
AND IN AUGUST THEY SEIZED
ANOTHER 33 BOXES FROM TRUMP'S
PROPERTY CONTAINING 103
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH OLIVIA TROYE
AND STEPHANIE GRISHAM.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE A GAME OF
TELEPHONE.
FORMER TRUMP LAWYER PAT PHILBIN
TOLD THE ARCHIVES THAT MARK
MEADOWS TOLD HIM THAT THERE WERE
A DOZEN BOXES WITH NEWSPAPER
CLIPPINGS.
DOES ANYBODY ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT
WAS IN THOSE BOXES?
THIS IS ALMOST COMICAL.
>> WELL, THAT WOULD -- [
INAUDIBLE ].
GOOD TO SEE YOU, JIM.
I'D SAY THAT PEOPLE DO BELIEVE
THAT THERE WERE NEWSPAPER
CLIPPINGS IN THERE BECAUSE THAT
IS HOW HE TRAVELED.
WE WOULD TRAVEL WITH THE BOXES
IS WHAT WE CALLED THEM AND THERE
WERE IN FACT NEWSPAPER CLIPPINGS
IN THERE BUT THERE WERE ALSO
WORK AND MAGAZINES AND THINGS
THAT HE WANTED TO SIGN AND SEND
TO PEOPLE.
SO THE BOXES DID ALWAYS HAVE
NEWSPAPER CLIPPINGS.
I WOULDPHILBIN WAS
TOLD THAT THERE WERE CLIPPINGS.
HE IS AN HONEST AND RIGHTEOUS
ATTORNEY, I DON'T THINK THAT HE
WOULD DO ANYTHING TO COVER UP
FOR DONALD TRUMP OR MARK MEADOWS
OR ANYONE ELSE.
SO I BELIEVE THAT HE IN GOOD
FAITH GAVE THAT MESSAGE ALONG.
MARK MEADOWS KNOWS BETTER.
I KNOW WHAT WAS IN THOSE BOXES.
THE BOXES FOLLOWED THE PRESIDENT
EVERYWHERE.
AND THERE WAS ALWAYS WORK IN
THERE WITH NEWSPAPER CLIPPINGS.
IT WAS A MESS.
IT WAS THE TRUMP FILING SYSTEM.
SO MARK MEADOWS HAD TO KNOW.
AND CERTAINLY TRUMP SEEMS LIKE
HE KNOWS SINCE HE SAYS HE
DECLASSIFIED EVERYTHING.
SO IF IT WAS JUST NEWSPAPER
CLIPPINGS, WHAT WAS IT THAT HE
DECLASSIFIED.
THAT IS MY QUESTION.
>> AND OLIVIA, IF YOU COULD PICK
UP WHERE SHE LEFT OFF WITH THIS
WHOLE MESS OF THE SCI DOCUMENTS
JUST MISSED IN WITH SCRAP BOOK
MATERIAL, PRESS CLIPPINGS AND SO
ON, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> YEAH, IT IS COMPLETELY
LUDICROUS INSANITY TO HAVE THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS JUST MIXED
IN LIKE SOUVENIRS.
MEANWHILE LIVES ARE ON THE LINE
HERE.
VERY SENSITIVE INFORMATION THAT
BELONGS TO THE U.S. GOVERNMENT,
IT CONDITION BELONG TO THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YEARS,
DECADES OF SERVICE COMING
TOGETHER TO DEVELOP THIS.
AND SO THE FACT THAT I'M VERY
CONFUSED ABOUT THE FACT THAT IT
SEEMS LIKE IT IS PING-PONG, WHO
KNEW WHAT WAS IN THE BOX, WHO
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS IN THE BOX.
AND I AGREE THAT I THINK PAT
PHILBIN WAS JUST REPEATING WHAT
WAS TOLD, BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS AND
WHO WAS INVOLVED AND WHAT
APPEARS TO BE THE COMPLETE
COVERUP.
>> AND STEPHANIE, TRUMP SPOKE
WITH THE CONSERVATIVE RADIO HOST
HUGH HEWITT, HE WAS ASKED WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF HE WERE TO FACE
CHARGES.
LET'S LISTEN TO THAT.
>> IF IT HAPPENED, I THINK THAT
YOU'D HAVE PROBLEMS IN THIS
COUNTRY THE LIKES OF CAN WHICH
PERHAPS WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
I DON'T THINK THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES WOULD STAND FOR
IT.
>> WHAT KIND OF PROBLEMS, MR.
PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK YOU'D HAVE BIG
PROBLEMS.
BIG PROBLEMS.
>> STEPHANIE, IS TRUMP ONCE
AGAIN SAYING THE RIOT PART OUT
LOUD?
>> ABSOLUTELY IN MY OPINION.
YOU KNOW, MAKE NO MISTAKE, I
THINK THAT WAS A CALL TO ARMS.
I THINK THAT HE IS ASKING FOR
THE EXTREMIST PART OF THE MAGA
COMMUNITY TO GET PREPARED IF
SOMETHING SHOULD HAPPEN TO THEIR
KING.
YOU KNOW, HE LEARNED NOTHING
FROM JANUARY 6 EXCEPT THAT HE
KNOWS HE HAS A GROUP OF VERY,
VERY LOYAL FOLLOWERS WHO WILL
BELIEVE ANYTHING HE SAYS AND
WILL DO ANYTHING HE SAYS, WHICH
IS EXACTLY WHAT WE SAW WITH THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE HEARINGS
WHEN THEY SHOWED VIDEOS OF SOME
OF THE PEOPLE ON THE CAPITOL
STEPS SAYING THAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID TO GO HOME OR, YOU KNOW,
THE PRESIDENT SAID MIKE PENCE IS
A TRAITOR, LET'S GET HIM.
IT IS CLEAR.
AND HE KNOWS VERY WELL THAT
THESE PEOPLE WILL DO WHATEVER HE
SAYS.
SO IN MY OPINION, IT WAS ANOTHER
CALL TO ARMS BECAUSE HE IS
GETTING NERVOUS AND IT IS
DISGUSTING AND ONCE AGAIN I'M
WAITING FOR REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP TO START SAYING NOW
THERE IS NO ROOM FOR VIOLENCE.
I MEAN, WE'RE RAMPING UP, WE'VE
GOT HOW MANY INVESTIGATIONS
GOING NOW.
SO IT IS SCARY TO ME.
I HATE HEARING THAT RHETORIC.
AND I HOPE -- I DON'T REALLY
THINK, BUT I HOPE THAT PEOPLE
WILL STEP UP AND SAY LET'S LET
THIS PLAY OUT.
>> AND OLIVIA, HAVING WORKED FOR
MIKE PENCE, I SUPPOSE YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT TRUMP IS SAYING
HERE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND WE'VE SEEN IT BEFORE.
WHAT HE IS TRYING TO DO IS
INTIMIDATION, TRYING TO SCARE
AMERICANS.
THAT IS WHAT HE IS TRYING TO DO.
HE IS TRYING TO MESSAGE AND SAY
HE IS ABOVE THE LAW AND I DON'T
WANT TOCCOUNTABLE.
>> AND SENDING A MESSAGE TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TOO.
>> EXACTLY.
THIS IS WHAT HE DOES.
>> AND STEPHANIE, LET ME ASK YOU
ABOUT THE NEW BOOK FROM PETER
BAKER AND HIS WIFE SUSAN GLASSER
WHO IS ALSO A REPORTER.
THEY SAY THAT MELANIA TRUMP
SLAMMED TRUMP'S HANDLING OF
COVID AT ONE POINT TELLING HIM,
ACCORDING TO THEIR BOOK, YOU'RE
BLOWING THIS, IT IS GOING TO BE
REALLY BAD AND YOU NEED TO TAKE
IT MORE SERIOUSLY.
THEY WRITE THAT HE DISMISSED HER
CONCERNS.
AND I'M WONDERING BECAUSE YOU
WORKED WITH THE FIRST LADY
DURING THIS ADMINISTRATION, YOU
WERE THERE DURING THE FIRST
MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC, DID YOU
HEAR ANY OF THIS?
>> OH, YES.
I MEAN, MELANIA TRUMP WAS THE
FIRST IN OUR ADMINISTRATION TO
REALLY COME OUT AND PUT VIDEOS
OUT SAYING WEAR A MASK.
SHE WAS VERY RESPONSIBLE WITH
COVID.
AND OUR WHOLE EAST WING WAS NOT
WORKING IN THE WHITE HOUSE WHEN
EVERYBODY ELSE WAS WORK IN THE
WITH WEST WING.
SO I KNOW SHE TALKED TO HIM
ABOUT TAKING IT SERIOUSLY AND HE
SAID THAT IT WILL BE FINE.
I'M NOT SURE ABOUT IF SHE SAID
YOU ARE BLOWING THIS, BUT IT
RINGS TRUE TO ME.
SHE WAS VERY, VERY CAUTIOUS AND
NERVOUS AND WORRIED ABOUT
AMERICANS AND STAFF AND HER
FAMILY WHEN COVID WAS GOING ON.
>> AND OLIVIA, I KNOW BECAUSE
YOU WORKED WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S OFFICE THAT THERE
WERE PEOPLE ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION, ACROSS THE WHITE
HOUSE AND THE EEOB WHO THOUGHT
TRUMP WAS BLOWING IT ON COVID.
I WOULD HEAR IT ALL THE TIME
FROM TRUMP OFFICIALS.
>> YEAH, AND THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
TRUE.
HONESTLY, IT IS INFURIATING WHEN
I READ THESE ACCOUNTS KNOWING
THAT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS HAVE DIED OF COVID.
I'M IN MY HOMETOWN EL PASO
VISITING AND THEY SUFFERED SO
HARD AS MANY OTHER CITIES DID.
I'M GLAD THE STORIES ARE COMING
OUT BECAUSE IT IS TRUE.
EVERYONE KNEW THE SITUATION AND
THIS IS THE RESULT OF A MAN WHO
EXHIBITED COMPLETE RECKLESSNESS
WHEN IT CAME TO LEADING OUR
COUNTRY DURING THAT REALLY,
REAL